Let's go next to Kathy from Wisconsin.
Kathy from Wisconsin.
You're on the air.
I how's the going?
Hi, how are you?
Good, how are you doing?
Well, to be honest, I don't really have much
of a question.
I was just wanting to listen in and I don't
know how to operate discords.
Oh, my goodness.
Well, tell me what how are you guys in Wisconsin?
You have wind power and it gets really cold,
right?
We do.
And it does.
And it seems that everything has been winterized
and there's no problems.
OK, we are.
We don't have any issues with that really
only time, so we lose power is mean as what
anyone with a really big storm and stuff like
that.
But nothing associated with.
No, no.
Wisconsin, Wyoming, Montana.
You know, a lot of these places are counterpoints
to the claim that the problem in Texas is
wind power.
You know, that it's not Caleigh.
And that's that's all that's all really, really
great.
And otherwise, things are OK.
Yeah, things are fine.
No, I do want to say I feel I mean, there's
a lot of people making jokes on social media,
and it's kind of easy to because we get that
amount of snow in temperature all the damn
time.
But I mean, I just want to make the point
to people that I mean, obviously I'm preaching
to the choir.
You know, this these people are not prepared
for this kind of stuff at all.
And they don't even have to deal with it to
no fault of their own.
So I don't know.
I'm just terrified for those people.
I'm in a lot of plant groups on Facebook and
a lot of them are just pretty much sacrificing
all of their plants because their houses are
30 degrees right now.
You know, I have to wait and go somewhere
else and mean that's the least of their problems.
But, yeah, it's not the people's fault in
Texas.
It's I mean, listen, they had a report a decade
ago that said, hey, here's how to prevent
this from happening again, because it happened
in 2011 and they just didn't do it.
Exactly.
Things that would be so common sense to us.
But, hey, what what growing zone are you in
in Wisconsin?
I think we would be five oh, OK, that's tough
for winter, right?
I mean, you can't grow much in winter.
No, I have I mean, even in the summer, if
all my plants inside, it's only a couple of
months that they can be outside anyway, but
definitely need a supplement.
We have some overcast here.
What's your best producing fruit or vegetable?
I don't do you a house.
Oh, so you're not growing that you doing?
Oh, wow, that's sad.
I would like to see you get into maybe tomatoes
or something.
I actually did just grow some tomatoes.
I will concede.
Yeah.
I'm getting those ready for spring, but beautiful.
Anyway, I'll go talk to marketing people.
Thanks, Kelly.
Kelly from was what's more interesting than
tomatoes?
I mean, there could be there could be nothing
more interesting than that.
All right.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up, because
we're going right back to the phones after
this.